announced in 2022 Thunderbolts will act
as a culmination of multiple storylines
from previous films featuring a cast
made up of previously seen anti-heroes
this includes Red Guardian Elena Bulova
Taskmaster the Winter Soldier U.S agent
and the Mysterious ghost
still feeds they'll be led by CIA
director Valentina Allegra de Fontaine
although it remains to be seen if
Harrison Ford's Thaddeus Ross will be a
member of the team we know Ford will be
showing up in Captain America Brave New
World but there's been no confirmation
that this character will appear in the
film just yet meanwhile Walking Dead
star Stephen Yoon has joined the cast
too with all signs suggesting that he
will be playing the super-powered
Goliath known as the Sentry directed by
Jake schreier and penned by Lee
seung-jin both of whom recently struck
gold with the Netflix series beef the
film seems poised to rock the very
foundations of the MCU expect to see
these ragtag heroes in action on
December 20th 2024